so this is too many birthdays well I
love the transition of various Stevens
he starts out like Marty Sherman from
the critic the critic son and then he
transforms let's see as a like young
teenager he transforms into Shia LeBouf
yeah
as an adult let's go with Steve
Guttenberg um then it becomes Danny
DeVito and then there's a brief
transition where he's Danny to be there
was the penguin and then he turns into
Santa Claus and a gyro and then the head
then I would go Iroh or crazy possessed
King Theoden from the two towers um and
then really old sands yes uh I really
like this one
ah what was he not our shark it's
definitely a you're only as old as you
feel
yeah that was it was a metaphor you're
only as old as you feel which is why I'm
10,000 Oh shucks we're adults um goofy
head if this is an episode where he
wants the three women at birthdays
because they don't really age so he
tries to give them birthdays and they
see his catch a lasso like I love pearl
in the background whispers pearl says
she's partied out yeah it's a hiding
behind her I hope nothing happens to the
pie would be Pam never to get bad yeah I
hope nothing happens I like wasted the
clown makeup it's supposed to be funny
why yeah why why that's a really brave
look for you oh uh yeah honestly the
this episode was really funny and really
poignant yeah um yeah I just it got
really dark there near the other one
yeah color scheme got really dark uh
she's crying with the pie I was like
this is legitimately upsetting it's is
both kind of yeah yeah it's boga it's
really funny and mailing them all
yeah setting oh the facial expressions
are that were really good especially
near that area with her doing the bite
of the big sad face of it hugging
amethyst um but it's uh yeah it's one of
those things where it's like on the one
hand it age is a funny thing
especially the mental state especially
now where there used to be sort of this
very clear lineup of how you know what
age you're supposed to and now 40 is the
new 12 system but but there needs to be
a very clear outline of like what age
you're supposed to you know have a job
if actually you find if you'll and now
still better than 40 all feel 14 that
we're gonna well sure this just live
your dream the ligature your 10 year old
train um yeah we're just because I'm
having fun doesn't mean you have to ruin
it for everybody yes it does somes
emphasized about right that was the
message that was the moral um but yeah
these are little bitch no there used to
be this very clear outline of what
you're supposed to be at one age and
stay even fight clips or talked about
ease like you know get a job I called my
dad I said I got job II so what now I
said I don't know get married do you
know there's just sort of this you know
not like law or rules but just sort of
now in the rate education is our love
decision what it's like but yeah like
financially at least in America there's
this big thing of like you know after
college it's like living at home for a
while is not that big a shock anymore
because it's still a pretty tough market
it's gotten better but it's still pretty
tough welcome universe I know in Japan
there's actually a thing where killing
your in-laws is a thing like a problem
because like you have to live in these
large families basically to save money
and so will be in law you may have to
live with your in-laws and like it
doesn't end well sometimes out Oh what
about it's not also like dump account
work themselves to death to is that also
there's like interesting uh interesting
stuff over there but not that like
there's an interesting stuff here either
um but yeah their hotels are great the
holy six feet down yeah um
six feet is the deluxe most fans so
sweet five four yeah that's the sweet
but but yeah there is sort of this
interesting thing where it's like and
even now I mean it's like there's so
many people I know that are my age and
be like they'll decorate their house and
they'll decorate their whole house like
I decorate my office you know and it's
not like ooh but it's not like it you
know interesting it's not like it
necessarily like oh what's wrong with
you thing or something like that there's
kind of this fun no but there's still
kind of a child at heart they want to
keep this stuff alive at least I got
this stuff in my office and everything
um so it's an interesting thing where
you know and now our libraries you know
where we stand shelves with blogs now
their shelves with DVDs and games and
blu-rays and stuff and it's not
necessarily like I'm not trying to say
oh that's all terrible it's just it's a
change though and I used to read no no I
mean I I've read a book after the flight
they of my book said I got I got books
too but they're all downstairs
it's like clearly it's like I'll look at
my collecting more ghosts uh you
probably have the neverending story down
there somewhere yes along with the
Necronomicon and in German no but yes
it's sort of an interesting thing about
you know some of the truths encounter on
what's going on right the first time I
really started thinking about it's gonna
be a weird you know it's a weird place
to first sort of be discover it but I
was watching goof troop I know it so
we're the plates discover it but there's
a line they had in there that just even
the dance don't remember it's just like
the kid the max is trying to act older
and somebody tells him you know max
you're young ones and then it's gone
forever it's just I've got the word
forever like with that and like just
give that shit I'll be like oh my god
like she's right that's just such a an
insane thing so it's what is he scarred
me for life
what Oh cuz when
our kid you do want to be older and you
want to act all their work fascinating
with stuff that's always like just a few
years older than honestly I didn't
mostly because the neighbor kids were in
high school and I noticed their giant
textbooks that were like this big and
I'm like no I'm good I'm good I'm fine
right where I'm at but it's one of those
things where it's like you always want
to act a little older and then something
about when I heard that line I'm like
okay no I should appreciate this now cuz
I do know when I get older it's like I
do want to grow up I do want to get
older I do want the responsibilities and
everything so but I you know I should
enjoy it what it's supposed to come but
it feels like it's the right time to
come so it I think this is sort of about
that where Steve is obviously a little
kid but the jewel makes him grow older
the only reason I wanted to get older
was to get out of school mmm yeah
obvious about that was about the
extended I still when I see kids like
waiting in line for the school bus going
to high school to say yeah there's the
don't miss that there's still this
Center every time a tough I have like so
go ahead not there anymore bike food
school you're working in college the
shit jobs that I had I'd skills like you
know it could be worse I could be given
high school ya know college at least I
knew I was making a choice to be there
how legit everybody's going to so you
have to go and and it blows and it's
like just if any high schoolers watching
now it gets better if you're watching
play believe it make good friends and
hang with them and just get through your
studies and everything it does get
better you anyways
there are some people who love high
school and actress those people I should
say out of that we have a word for
people like them serial killers
I'm hearing if you like I school that's
fine but uh we could never be friends
yeah I kid I kid no I'm serious
you know it's just joking but um yeah so
it's an interesting and I think now
because there is such as fascination
with nostalgia and so many adults it
helps so many adults are talking about
kid things you know and it's not
uncommon us not us at all but but there
are people that can I mean this besides
me equation you can get to adult and not
have any of that childhood and that
that's not good I mean child who is such
an important part you have to you have
to function as an adult like this yeah
but there's no unusually good quality
like in Japan like just only living in
your basement and like the only outside
world you see is when you like poke your
eyes through the blinds like yeah maybe
social interaction you need to go
outside you need to get a job you need
to work you need to eat stew usually to
survive some basic functioning yeah you
don't need discipline you do your
response there's a legitimate excuse
like if you're legitimately mentally ill
that's a difference you know um but at
the same time like I I don't know I
you only feel is all the you're only as
old as you feel in my opinion until your
body just finally says now and you die
but like at some point you finally hit
that part of life I know I can't like do
the things I used to be able to do but I
yeah I know what what when I die I feel
like I've been stuck perpetuating about
the age of 25 26 for 10 years now I like
that's just about how old I feel like
and just like that I still feel like I'm
in my mid-20s like ya know mentally I'm
kind of the same way my body's telling
me a different story uh yeah I've had to
treat battle differently now I do I do
not feel like I am physically or
mentally in high school because I was
like screw high school I still feel like
I'm like post college like yeah yeah no
I think it's I wonder that is a common
thing if that's like a now thing or a
common thing that's just always kind of
been like most people and they're you
know
I mean where are their 30s now if we
still most people just yeah yeah I know
I'm still like my holidays or something
like that I said we know our bodies what
Sonia let's do a repeal looks let's be
honest that we're also in a first world
country yeah
despite everybody trying to be like her
shifting shifting Obama the country's
going to hell like no go go live like in
a third-world country and see what it's
like like we got it pretty sweet still
yeah there's definitely politics aside
we're still doing pretty well yeah I
mean there's no math no way not like
you'd age much faster in Afghanistan our
version of mid-30s is going to be way
different than there so I always got to
keep that in mind and Plus as a modern
like we're in the 21st century like I
can't like can you imagine 1915 Dad what
it would have been like for one thing I
don't think we would we'd be working
some shit job somewhere yeah we'd be
shoveling coal because certainly we
would not be doing this ha ha did you
see the latest movie Magnum oh yes I did
when he waved the cigar just go to the
street corner and review it putting all
the patrons yes I go gather around us
like we'll be on our soap boxes
explaining what we thought
honestly knowing us we would have been
one of the crappy bought Phil shows
we've been running around doing a crap
we went we labelled like just re bomb
just like you know you changed your
opinions we have opinions um but and
then we sound crazy gonna be talked
about like these people I it wouldn't
stop we would have had our own shitty
vaudeville show that was simply making
fun of other shitty shows that's what we
would have been doing um and like most
actors we probably would have lived to
our like 40s because we would have been
doing pratfalls and broken half our ribs
by the age of 20 Alec so so be gone um
but you know what this remind me of yeah
no you know this do remind me of and I
don't know how many people and probably
not that many I have seen the show metal
really good show uh surprisingly you
remember Fox's Peter Pan the Pirates yes
you made a last episode no the last
episode yeah actually it's exactly like
this I maybe maybe I saw it and denote
was the last episode so what starts to
grow up like a key editor man yeah hook
actually Hoku is voiced by Tim Curry
that gives you an idea how genius the
show oh there that show he's probably
the best Captain Hook ever oh I don't
get your pitch yeah and he actually like
sort of tells Peter Pan like you know
you will never be a man you will always
be a little boy and you'll be
embarrassing you don't ever say it cuz
like he's about to kill her happy you're
gonna be a virgin the rest of you don't
know it was vital sense to like a really
dark scene because like he's about to
kill heart he's about to like you know
I've had enough you killing the water
myungjin that sounds gonna show you then
he gets his way out by saying I at least
have grown up to be a man I have had
responsibilities I've been at schedule
been a gentleman I've been a man he's
like you will always be a boy it'll be a
nothing you'll be just this little
snot-nosed whatever and it gets to him
and he flies off and he you know lets go
whatever huh and he a decides I want to
grow up I want to be a man and he starts
to happen as he starts to grow up
Neverland starts to fall apart this was
the prequel the book kind of kind of XS
he's growing up Neverland is falling
apart this made him this way was free
hook I think yeah I think so that's okay
let's see hook was not one that maybe
merrily maybe the same time so he's
getting older and older like you know
and then like an old man and Neverland
is becoming greater in sludge and
falling apart and everything and so it's
like King Arthur it's like the land and
the king uh and it was really fucking
good it was a really good shove you go
this is one of our nostalgic shows so
late 80s way early 90s boxes played a
man in the buy it was probably like but
that without ever actually doing you
know the Peter Pan story straight up
like they really inspire the closest to
the book I mean it was like they really
really got the spirit of the characters
of the book and everything in the
darkness of it and it was really well
done it just reminded me a lot of that
again just sort of like value your youth
I mean don't stay there forever grow up
but value your age I think is always
what I got out of is whatever age you're
at just value it you know to be in the
present if you can't prepare for the
future thing the bad but enjoy this
essentially it just can become settled
men like us why ed in our 30 complain
about you stupid Millennials you're
texting in your kids oh but no I like
episode I like anything that really
addresses age in an interesting way and
I thought this did and I asked you
preach amazing episode yeah it wasn't
quite too preachy I mean like a kid
could watch it just oh it's getting
older oh no you know but we can watch it
and see like you know wow like you said
you're only as old as you feel
um so yeah I thought was really good
many yeah I thought was I felt a very
pointy of the that was funny the
animation was good that the color
schemes and everything we're good um you
know with when things are getting darker
it was visually darker as well so yeah I
thought was a really good episode I the
strongest one we've seen so far um so
yeah anything else yeah we got yeah I
think we covered it pretty well yeah
bright ranch for a while there so uh
good stuff we'll see you the next one
later